please give it up for Shane Lynn MA the
CEO of zola well you know you made me
wanna
[Music]
[Applause]
CEO and co-founder of zola so I think I
can consume most of you here raise your
hand if you have gotten married and used
over for your wet wedding registry yeah
raise your hand if you've been to a
wedding where Zola was the wedding
registry more hands and raise your hand
if you've just heard of Zola in general
oh cool well if you are not yet
acquainted with Zola I hope that you
very soon will be and for those of you
who don't know what we do we are the
fastest growing wedding registry and
wedding startup in the country and we
are also one of the fastest growing
e-commerce startups in the country we
started four years ago and we've set out
with a mission to use design and
technology to reimagine the wedding
registry experience for couples getting
married today those couples just happen
to be the Millennial Generation with
different to any other registry you
might know of in that we work directly
with 500 brands brands that you might be
familiar with classic registry brands
like KitchenAid or Cuisinart or Vitamix
that you see in every kitchen we also
partner with brands that you might be
less familiar with that a more
up-and-coming like Lisa mattress
parish's home so knows as well as
experiences like blue apron SoulCycle
wine tasting and in the last four years
since we started it's been a four-year
hustle so far we've raised over forty
million in BC funding last year we did
our Series C of twenty five million and
I was one of the depressingly tiny 4% of
female founder CEOs who raised the Serie
C in 2016
thank you thank you well I hope that
many of you here will help us drive up
that number over the coming years so I
want to tell you how we've seen
explosive growth in the business and to
do that I wanted to start at the
beginning so this is a picture of me and
my mother and my brother isn't my
brother cute he looks a bit different
now and and when I was growing up I was
not like other little girls I think many
of my friends wanted to be pilots or
astronauts or firefighters or teachers
and I wanted to be this guy who knows
who this guy is Jerry Yang he is the
founder of Yahoo and Yahoo you know well
today I know most of us here are
probably Google users Yahoo started as
really the company that helped us access
the internet for the first time Jerry
Yang started the company Yahoo with the
idea that you wanted to make the
internet a friendly accessible fun place
and if it wasn't for Jerry Yang starring
Yahoo there wouldn't have been many of
the great companies that exist today
like Google Facebook he really set the
stage for all of us here growing up I
lived and wanted to be like Jerry and
when I looked at him I saw another
immigrant who started with very little
but worked really hard and has now had a
lasting impact on the world and when I
looked at how do I get to Silicon Valley
and start a company like Jerry I didn't
know anyone who had ever even heard of
Silicon Valley so was reading a lot of
articles and read that Jerry and other
great Silicon Valley started found of
winter Stanford so I thought I guess you
have to go to Stanford
at work so was lucky enough to throw my
application in get accepted and got to
go there for two years to do my MBA
after my MBA I of course went to work at
Yahoo and the best day of my two years
ago who was when I passed Jerry Yang in
the corridor and he didn't see me but I
definitely saw him and I silently
freaked out I to this day still have
never actually met him or spoken to him
so if anyone here knows him please come
and see me after but most importantly I
learned at Yahoo from the best product
people who now run product some of the
best companies in this country I then
took that those skills and moved to the
East Coast to join Gilt Groupe
as the first product person there I
learnt a great deal and most importantly
I got to meet great people like Kevin
Ryan the founder of gilt who also
founded Business Insider in and
Nobu
Noguchi who was the head of the user
experience design team and with Kevin
and Nobu and now my co-founders at zola
a gilt I learned a lot about how to
build a great ecommerce engine and what
the requirements are for any explosives
ecommerce company really it came down to
a simple but the hard equation and that
equation is you need to build in demand
intent and virality into your product to
see product markets is but that's not
enough you also need to build an
emotional connection to your users so
I'll share a bit about how we saw this
work both at guilt and then how we
iterated and improved upon that during
our time at solar so far so this is Nobu
and I
so Nobu guilt I mentioned was the head
of the user experience design team and
you can see some of his design genius in
action here in this middle photo and
this is Australia Day the best day of
the year as Ola and Nobu somehow created
a hat which is the Opera House out of a
few random paper plates in the office
but really what he and I learned
together at gilt was so crucial to the
formation of zola we learnt about first
foremost how to create demand intent how
do you define an e-commerce product that
customers then led very clearly and
quickly down that ecommerce conversion
funnel to one to check out the way that
we saw this work at gilt was that Kevin
had created a company that offered great
beautiful design brands at 80 percent of
retail price for a limited time only in
limited quantities it was the first time
anyone had seen this before and it draws
a great number of people to check out
really quickly when we were thinking
about a new idea to start and the year
was 2013 and that was the year that all
my friends were getting married at the
same time I'm sure many of you have had
that same year if not you will and that
was the year that I had to buy a lot of
wedding presents from a lot of
registries that at that time with a
traditional department store wedding
registries we saw there was a clear
opportunity here and we saw that there
was a ready demand built into the
wedding registry market two million
people get married every year that means
two million people have to create a
wedding registry for the most part if
you don't want gifts that people just
randomly buy for you we realize it's a
huge market who knew there was 19
billion dollars of wedding registry
gifts per chillingly
purchased in the US alone every year and
for the entire
the global industry it was a 300 billion
dollar market I think that surprised all
of us and and still continues to
surprise many investors so when we were
thinking about the market is big enough
but how do we really differentiate and
build something that we know our friends
and couples today deserve
we started by thinking about what our
users using today and we did a lot of
research we spoke to hundreds of couples
and we heard that what couples were
doing was they were going into
department stores they were faced with a
sea of products they had no idea what
they were doing or what they should be
doing and it was it was painful to be
led through things that all look the
same where there was the same kind of
coffeemaker same kind of plate pots and
pans that was the physical experience
and it led to a lot of fighting on the
right you can see these were the DePalma
store registries as they looked in 2013
and some of them still look like this
today from an e-commerce perspective it
looks cold it's impersonal it looks like
a checkout card we know couples today
deserve better we've started to talk to
couples about what would they do if they
could do anything with their wedding
registry and the same themes kept coming
up again and again couple said we want
to register for products and experiences
and cash and we don't want to set up
three different registries to do that
which is what they were doing before
Zola so we built a registry that you let
you register for anything you wanted or
in the one place a common complaint we
heard was that when you register with
department stores they were as people
bought from your registry there and
things would just start turning up at
your house and you had no idea what was
coming who sent it what's in the box
you weren't even ready to receive it yet
often you might have been off on your
honeymoon or getting married and yet
things just kept coming this was a very
easily solved using technology all we
did was we said we will not send any
to the couple until they're ready to
actually receive it which is a huge
innovation in the e-commerce space and
still something that only we do today
third we heard couples want to make
their registry as beautiful as the rest
of their wedding day so in this country
on average couples spend $35,000 on one
day they want it to be beautiful they
spend a lot to make it reflect who they
really are and that extends to wedding
registries we let couples personalize
what it means to have a registry we made
it mobile because that's where couples
live today we let them designate
anything as a group gift because it
turns out people with kind of hacking
this by registering for a lot of things
they didn't want then taking it all back
to the store after they received it to
return it for the thing they really
wanted you should just be able to
register for the thing you actually want
in the first place and let people
contribute to that and then lastly
customer service every single customer
we interviewed said to us I have no what
I no idea what I'm doing because I'm
getting married for the first time
please help me understand what to do and
that's where our customer service really
lends a hand and does what we say in our
tagline which is we do anything for love
so number two virality the way we saw
this at gilt and we learn a great deal
with we saw and gilt we were one of the
first to really privatize the idea of
refer a friend or invite a friend we
were one of the very first to launch the
invite a friend get $25 that was at a
time when gilt with a members-only site
people wanted a lot of credit to spend
on gilt and there weren't that many
referral programs out there so it was
unique and a lot of people did share
gilt we also were the first to come up
with what is something I'm really proud
of gilt the personal invitation link
where we gave every member their own
clink that they could share with friends
anywhere and we could track back to to
that person how many people they refer
and give them credits accordingly and
that drove huge growth of guilt in the
early days it was virality that we had
built into the product that really drove
the growth and we knew we had to figure
out a way to do it at zola we also as
all I have the benefit of having natural
virality because when someone gets
married
on average you invite 150 guests to your
wedding so the way we think about
building virality into zola's product is
that if we can build a registry that is
beautiful that is easier to buy from
than any other registry then every gas
coming to that registry will want to
tell their friends who are married
getting married or will want to use it
themselves when they get married and we
just have to remind them that we exist
number three last but not least most
important part of this ecommerce
equation is how do you build an
emotional connection so when I joined
gilt
the first thing I did was interview all
the users in multiple focus groups
surveys one-on-one interviews about gilt
and I kept hearing the same things again
and again the same words where I am love
gilt I'm obsessed
I'm addicted I cannot stop shopping and
those words really became the benchmark
of what it meant to have a real
emotional connection with users the way
that we thought about how to bring this
to life within the gilt product was in
the mobile app I don't know if any of
you remember or still have it but
there's a notification that goes off
when the sales start and that was
something that we would hear users say
oh the sales start at 9:00 a.m. on the
west coast and I'm driving to work but
when I hear that notification I pull
over to the side of the road and because
I have to start shopping right there and
then otherwise I might miss out on
something
and that kind of emotional connection
and commitment with something that we
thought about bringing to zola in some
way the way that we have done that is we
have looked at how can we bring this out
through what we're hearing from couples
they love and they want from Zola and
that is really the next phase of our
business it's going beyond just the
wedding registry to help couples plan
more of their wedding we for the first
four years of our business have been
these are focused on solving the painful
parts about wedding registry
but we've been hearing users ask from us
or pull from us things they also want us
to help where things like could you help
me with my baby registry could you help
me furnish more of my home or could you
help me plan more of my wedding and with
only in the last few months decided we
would expand beyond registry to attack a
bigger market and between those three
options we landed with weddings we
wanted to help people really plan the
wedding from the day they get engaged
through their first year of newlywed
life we launched solar wedding is two
months ago with the idea being we could
help couples plan through a checklist a
guest list and a free wedding website
and we could do all of this for free
because our business is registry during
the two years sorry the two months since
we launched solar weddings we've had
overwhelming reception from couples who
are using the tools to make their
wedding planning easier and as we look
forward to our next step we're looking
at how can we build more to help couples
with more of their wedding to make it
from them currently the most stressful
time of your life into how could it be
an easier simple fun time of your life
and really the reason we're doing it is
because
we know it's not just about building
product markets here we have that we've
shown that in the numbers it's about how
can we continue to build an emotional
connection and if we can do that then
like Jerry Yang at Yahoo like we did it
guilt like we're starting to see at zola
we can have a real impact on people's
lives thank you
[Applause]